let's take one more phone call today at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 or maybe 2 more we'll
see who's on the line with us now are
you slow David it's uh Jarrett from
downtown PA always great to hear from
you hey is Downingtown near New Hope
Pennsylvania you hope one second I'll
just google it really if you've got a
google it i'm guessing it's probably not
that that is nice sense there I'm
curious because I was at I was at a
wedding in New Hope Pennsylvania over
the weekend and it's very close I mean I
think it's just a few miles from the New
Jersey border and it was a very very new
and unique experience there were a lot
of people praying in the restaurant
where I had lunches as their meals were
brought out it was just generally a very
different experience for me uh in any
case feel from a comment on that or I'm
glad to answer a question well that's in
talks I'm in not just but ok Chester
County PA but um are what I wanted to
talk about his arm Lewis when Tom how's
he doing and uh uh since some was yet
currently so uh I spoke to Louis this
morning in fact because we had a
technical question that Louis was
uniquely suited to answer for us Louis
seems to be doing well it was about
10:45 local time when I called a many it
sounded like I had roused him from a
very very deep sleep so I've not spoken
to him it was like a two-minute
conversation I'm gonna speak to him
later today and maybe I'll be able to
have a better report next week but if
the fact that he sounded sleepy at 10:45
a.m. is any indication I think Louis is
doing pretty well
very nice and do you know if he could
like I know this is going to sound
pretty uh crazy because you're not
really Louis but do you know if he could
if Louis could start his own right um
not so much podcast but like something
like one youtuber he's like like a
thirty minute for heat like when if
Schultz was taken off MSNBC he start
doing like these little 30-minute things
on YouTube right waiting just
one down like what's on the news or you
know what's on his mind or anything not
I mean totally yeah a bunch of people
have suggested Louis do something maybe
a music review show I don't know uh of
course I can't speak for Louis but I am
going to when I speak to him later today
I will tell him that numerous people are
on record saying they'd like for him to
do something and I think it would be
great if he would do that
thank you so much for the call I do have
to move on I hope to be able to speak to
you again in the future